gets his first touch of the game Rustin
interception bounces back to Graves here's
a Genny Malin L Graves over to Eric Carlson his
Wier is right into the Bread Basket of the cor
no rebound he's moving forward towards the net
to let that rer go face off win by Sydney Crosby
rinse and repeat that statement as the puck comes
in on deor that's kicked out alexc run into by
Raquel Works through it and Ellie tolvanen will
snap it over to will borgan only goal this season
for borgan was outdoors in the Winter Classic made
the most of it tolven and shot hung on to by jar
and really in a season where Seattle started off
pretty wobbly he has steadied the ship and gotten
them right back in the mix here's Tai cier his
snapshot is handled on D by jari Jaden Schwarz
out at Center for Granton tan they call him
turbo his pass picked off by his old college
teammate a Char and a head Squints Carter with a
step shots turned aside by dor Jeff Carter this
is a this has turned the clock back 10 years
car coming down the right wing Scoops it cross
ice Justin Schultz catches it over the line to
Schwarz his wrer off the right leg a jari good
stop through traffic and he'll cover and the
pen Shuffle it out to Center Malin pushes it
ahead o Conor with a burst to speed shooting
and a save made by dord got passed byy Malin
alexc back ahead for Yanni gourd from the Tampa
Bay Lightning lost the [__] in Center there
it's Rael back in for the pens across stel to the
net and fr couldn't connect to Crosby it hits Sid
but Sid was blocked out by the big body of Alexia
chips it over to Pon Rings it around leang trying
to get to it g nearly knocked it away Malin has
it Wier is off the leg of decor and this last
chance is of get Malin in the high slot Carlson
in his own end turns it over wiberg in front
can connect to Schwarz up top it's rker Evans
snapshot kicked out by jari Pittsburgh trying
to manufactur something comes back to L Tang
away from wiberg chips it over to Pon The Long
Reach handles it rtier knocked down by dord ayay
man that's that's a tough way to make a living
rosby able to knock it back to Graves his
shot wide gel off the end wall to Carlson
across recel over the body of the court but
not over the line but they haven't cracked them
yet and they'll be in New York City tomorrow
taking on the Rangers so they're probably happy
about this earlier travel to get to Manhattan
with the time change Kel shot block on its
way to the goal he's right to the puck though
Crosby turns and shoots the court a save and a
clear Marcus Pon coming out of
his own Zone a launch It Forward
from Malin ahead Rusty's got a man in front o car
scor perfect passing from Pittsburgh in an early
strike in the second it's one nothing the crack
in the middle of a change quick stretch pass by
the Penguins that's getting mon with a little one
touch and how about Brian r on the backand hangs
on hangs on the patience of Joe on the backand
to wait for OC to open up for that one timer and
OC knew he had to elevate it he just gets enough
to get it over the glove Drew Conor sixth of the
Season he adds to his career high now 15 points
on the year as he'll tip it back out and here come
the pens right in the Wave It's rust in shot save
dord if anything is clear a shot def Flex wide
it's the oh a puck comes right back in on dord
he makes the save gel with a chance there but he
finished quickly Brian rust is getting back to
full strength they score Sydney Crosby fires it
past the cord goal number 574 for Sid to zip if
he's looking for go tender interference or if he
thought the puck was high stick as the puck goes
around the umbrella eventually to Chris lat tang
and Sid open up for that one- timer Sid gets those
hands so close together that's not a slapper
one timer that's almost a snapper one timer
that takes almost Herculean strength cracking back
in two goals in 2 minutes and 43 seconds for the
Penguins who've come out firing here to start
this second and Malin comes right back in shot
saved by DOR didn't get all of it the names that
these guys are surrounded by in these categories
all in the Hall of Fame Houston and shot is right
into the Bread Basket of deor no rebound one hand
on his stick what an effort to get it back to Pon
it's Malin for oconor drops it back down L Malin
to ' Conor his shot is off the court Pon drives
it to the net wide lat Tang gust passing for Pon
is shot change direction Malin chips it back for
Pon with's a four check again they just all over
the Kracken L Tang to Pon connects to Malin hopped
off his stick loose Pucket Genny Malin for rust
Wier and a save made by dord when that message
is received it goes a long way and clearly after
the season the Kraken just had there's a lot
of respect for the man behind the bench there
in Seattle 100% I never knew how good a coach
he was when he was in Philadelphia he'll knock
it around to gr chips it back down low def Flex
to Pon and quickly up top for Carlson he walks
the line AER wide ER off the outside of the net
okor back to Graves here's Carlson his snapshot
block back down low hon in pushes it for o Conor
Eller watched by Tatar swings it back to Carlson
this snapshot deflected by OK Conor and dor gets
a save on that hopped off his stick pens maybe
a chance short-handed it's Russ with a Char Here
Comes rust he throws it in front knocked down by
Schultz lost Underneath Him here's rer Evans
back into his own zone for Tomas Tatar finds
Kyler Yamamoto back to Tatar is centering pass g
a great stop his best of the game on Schwarz in
tight to Eller and then down the other end Thomas
Tatar Feats the Schultz the deflection he still
gets a lot in that backand to Center smart play
by Rael two nothing Le that situational hockey
th the dropping that Puck and thought wiser of
it Everly back in off the crossbar as that one
over Jar's glove but right off IR penguin Zone
dishes to Everly and he just little kiss off the
iron 50 seconds on the power play Evans leaned
on by ER comes back to borren quickly over to
mccan his shot is off the crossbar and out of
play that's what we're talking about shooting
Jared mccan was they work it around they get
him aan one little dust off and he lets it Fly
oh man can he ABS you give him that time and that
space how precious every point is that one point
kept him out last year go a loose Puck comes to
Raquel two on1 with Crosby Raquel across Crosby
backhander save made to C the rebound and then
Sid taking the pass from Ricard Rael forehand
backhand and oh that allows York Strand exit he
finds Justin Schulz coming in for the Kraken his
shots blocked to the bench goes dord extra skater
on with two and a half to go for Seattle penguins
in front two nothing Raquel has the Pucket
center pushes it Forward Cosby a chance he seals
it by Ricard Rael the St with it Jake gentel
chips it out it gets knocked down but Raquel
stays with it and Sid opened up on that
left side trusting that Ricard Rael was
going to be strong on the stick get it to
him and then Bulls up and this Pittsburgh
sports double header has kicked off with
a two-point Party on Fifth Avenue as the
Penguins snap the nine game winning streak for
the Seattle Kraken with a three nothing shut out